hi I'm Nancy Roman director of private
partnerships and communications at the
World Food Program where the world's
largest humanitarian agency hiding under
worldwide and I believe these
fundamental power that people have to
transform the world now that they didn't
have ten years ago is an ability to do
something as an individual mattered part
thanks to the internet and social media
people can participate in huge global
issues like ours hunger in a few by
doing something very immediate very
manageable by giving online by sharing a
thought by sharing story about a hungry
person somewhere who can be helped I
urge anyone who wants to get involved to
go to wfp org or two we feedback work
and you can make a difference one person